all right i got a question for you peter
as we draft the most intriguing figures
of the next two week in the nfl who was
the last top five pick
that came from outside
a power five conference
and the hit is at the wide receiver uh
that helps
how about cars how about carson wentz
uh
one year too early corey davis 2017 from
western michigan i believe taken by the
titans i think that's the answer is that
the answer all right i got it right um
yes
and it isn't even
just
i just happen to know it for a change ah
wow oh it's got to be kyle shanahan i i
i that
we don't we you know even if he knows
what he's going to do we don't know what
he's going to do what's he going to let
on what's he going to let us know
what clues are going to be there how
quiet he's going to keep things and you
mentioned the whole jay cutler
dynamic with mike shanahan from 2006
when the broncos just came out of the
blue traded up with the rams to pick
number 11 to get jay cutler
kyle learned from his dad don't show
anything and even when you're in a spot
where there's no reason to keep it quiet
he's keeping it quiet the betting
market's all over the place on who the
third overall pick is going to be only
shanahan knows so i'm i'm i'm fascinated
to see what he lets us know between now
and two weeks from last night
i'm gonna say terry fontenot the new
general manager of the atlanta falcons
for a very very simple reason
he's going to have more choices
than i think any general manager high in
this draft he's either going to be able
to sit there at number four
and take a quarterback he's either going
to be able or he's going to sit there at
number four
and take kyle pitts or his choice of you
know jamar chase or you know one of the
one of the receivers
or he's gonna get an offer he can't
refuse
and so
right in the saddle
in his first draft as a general manager
to me the most intriguing general
manager in this draft
terry fontenot
i'm going to go with bill belichick
who's the combination gm head coach of
the patriots even though he doesn't have
the gm title he's in charge we talked at
length earlier about what they've done
this off season where they sit at number
15 rare that they're not in the 20s rare
that they're not in the low 20s rare
that they're not in the 30s frankly for
the draft they're in a position where if
they do want to make a move
they could
and so
as pick
four
five six
seven eight as those happen
you're gonna have that constant worrying
of the when could we hear there's been a
trade and the patriots have moved up
because as you said no one knows what
the patriots are going to do so what is
belichick going to do it's not like he's
going to let us know but we have to
consciously and constantly be aware of
the possibility they're gonna make that
move to try to get their next franchise
quarterback
my next pick is justin fields because i
think he has
been on a roller coaster uh going back
to the beginning of last season
first of all he is one of the players
who
is a very big reason why the big ten
played football you know he starts a
petition drive to get football going
back he has some big games but he has a
couple of clunkers against indiana and
against northwestern so now clearly it's
trevor lawrence you know at the top and
then justin fields and then the year
ends and all of a sudden you know you've
got you've got zach wilson who jumps up
and who jumps ahead of justin fields and
now he's in this netherlands
you know we don't know if justin fields
is going to be picked third
or whether he's going to be picked 12th
we don't have any idea but as far as
players and where he could go at what
level of the draft how aggressive teams
are going to be to get justin fields
i think he is a really interesting
figure coming in to this draft
hell i think i saw that charlie casterly
former nfl general manager has fields at
24 which seems
just a bit lower than where fields is
ultimately going to go i'll go kyle
pitts the guy that we heard from to
start the segment because he could be
the fourth overall pick of the falcons
he could be the 10th overall pick of the
cowboys and the cowboys and this is kind
of a hybrid for me because when you look
at all the offensive players that we're
going to see in the top 10 the cowboys
have needs defensively they
they they basically have the first pick
in the draft if it's all nine offensive
players because they need to go defense
but if kyle pitts is there at 10 or if
he creeps past five
will the cowboys will jerry jones will
he be able to overpower anyone in the
organization and move up he's infatuated
with pits and i'm fascinated to see
where he goes because peter i think he
could he could go as high as four to
atlanta if they just decide to say screw
it we're using the pick and we're not
taking a quarterback
yeah i i like that one that was gonna be
my next one but my my last one mike is
going to be trey lance
and i hate to just lean on quarterbacks
like this but
trey lance is fascinating to me because
look he's played one football game in
the last 400 days
he was not very good in that football
game that football game was against
central arkansas
and so it just reinforced
a lot of people's questions about how
long will it be before trey lance is
going to be able to be a
a very good quarterback at that next
level and look
i think he's going to be i think he's
got a chance to be a really really good
nfl quarterback he's got all the tools
in order to do that but the fact is
he hasn't done it against a high level
of competition
he's been off basically for most of the
last 16 months
and so now you look at them and you say
we need to really examine this player
closely
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports